first of all I would like to say that
I'm really happy to be here again last
year I was on the track to talking about
image segmentation today some different
kind of research of mine I'm
representing the Silesian University
technology of as a PhD candidate and the
future processing as a software
developer and I would like to talk about
mind-reading I will say something more
later but the agenda for for today is
the how does the brain work of course I
don't know how the brain works but I
will show you some kind of basic
knowledge I will talk about brain
reading devices so how we can read this
brain activity and this state-of-the-art
applications and I will not fly off to
the future too much the state-of-the-art
applications are impressive enough to
show it on the presentation not go into
science fiction style and I will show
you some code from my research my PhD
research and it will be in Python and
how to start to read minds in Python so
in the last episode okay I hope I have
okay I have in front so I'm showing this
to show you what is my background in
image segmentation this is the
presentation on YouTube from a year ago
so I'm showing it to promote the video
to promote the work of my colleagues
from k3d repeater there is some
application about heart segmentation
using this visualization library and of
course to show you some much of it of
what I was doing last year because I
will be rewriting to this or work of
mine so how does the brain work this
charming pictures and picture shows
perfectly die
what what neuroscience call the catch-22
of the brain so if the brain were so
simple that we could understand it we
will be so simple that we couldn't and
this is the sketch and we still don't
know how the brain works
we are working on it and by this picture
I would like to promote the Wade bite
but why blog post about neural link I
will be talking some of it some about it
later and of course we are on the long
road to the know in the brain like the
professor Jeff Lichtman from Harvard
said if the all we need to know about
the brain was a mile we are just a few
inches on this road so what can you see
here are the building blocks of the of
the brain the neurons and the picture on
the left is from the work of Santiago
Ramon y Cajal is a Spanish
neuroscientist very well known and these
drawings are from 1905 so more than 100
years ago and today the state-of-the-art
methods of fluorescent photography of
neurons so we can say we we know how the
neuron looks like but the bigger
question is how we can map all these
neurons in our brain in the structure so
we know how how what is the neuron but
we need to find the connections between
neurons between these neurons this is
video from National Geographic Channel
on YouTube and what you can see on this
video are the photographs of slice by
slice like physically slicing the
fragments of the rat brain and each each
photograph is a one slice of nanometer
accuracy and what we need to do is to
segment this images using for example
deep learning methods is the state of
the art here for example this flood-fill
in networks are used in the article to
segment brains and what we can do we can
map this on the 3d plane and map the
whole brain this is the ultimate goal to
map the whole brain and to know the
structure of the whole brain so if if we
know the structure of the whole brain
one one one more thing we can use
projects like like neo brain game
simulator alter said it is the biggest
in the world project to map the
connectome of the brains to connect on
what how the neurons are connected and
it is not released yet but they say it
will be like collective intelligence
attempt to map the whole brain and this
is the ultimate goal and some kind of
game to help them map the brain I should
start it ok and if we know the mapping
of the brain we need to simulate the
electrical activity of this brain
because the task of each neuron is to
collect the neuron ID the electrical
activity of other neurons and to pass
them to the other neurons this is the
basic idea if we know the connectome of
the brain all the connections and all
the neurons activity we can simulate the
brain what you can see here is the
difficult X simulator and you can see
some activity on the back of the brain
it is the visual area and here we have
16 million neurons and 4 billion
connections and it's still five thousand
times less than in the proper human
brain and you need to note that this
simulation was generated not on like a
standard PC but computational cluster so
even if we know the whole brain and we
have software for simulating the neurons
it is still challenged to simulate it on
the some hardware so we are in terms of
hardware we are long way long way ago ok
so if you are familiar with the typical
mathematical model of artificial neuron
you need to know that the biologically
plausible model has a time domain
information so not only input and output
but the pattern of output like what is
the pattern of spikes
so the
neuron activity spikes when it collects
the activity from other neurons and in
some fresh cold it will spike his own
electrical potential and this is someone
some called it like a third generation
of artificial neural networks because in
the same number of neurons we can
accumulate more information because of
this time domain and this is the
simulation of how it can work
so each neuron has its own pace of
spiking or dielectric activity and we
have on the input some kind of for
example video or a second sequence of
the data and we can interpret the output
the output spikes or the Train spike
trains it's called spike trains we can
interpret it as a input to other
classifier or just interpret the time
domain of this data and there are pretty
many of these brain simulators or
spiking neural network simulator
simulators last time I checked this list
on the top there were more than 20 of
these simulators the ones marked with
Python with the snake are Python based
or Python API and these are the most
interesting ones digi cortex is one you
have seen on the slide before and one
that this particular interesting this
spawn it's functional brain it can solve
some tasks like fluid intelligence tasks
like IQ test or something like this just
by simulating how the brain works and
like biologically plausible simulation
and after 50 years and thousands of
research research papers and works we
know that this complicated structure of
neurons is somehow structured in areas
of our brains in each brain there are
some areas that are connected to some
are responsible for some tasks I would
like to focus on the vision
Association area so the back of the
brain this is where the vision processes
are happening and I would like to you to
know the motor cortex so on the middle
of the head there is the brain area for
all the movements and the coordination
of your move of your movement so if we
know somehow how the brain works in the
basics we can measure this activity and
it will be short introduction to brain
reading devices I will start from the
triangle good fast cheap you know when
you are making a product you can do it
good and fast but not cheap or good and
cheap but not fast then that something
on the on the middle of this triangle
doesn't exist in case of brain reading
we have precise and I mean by precise I
mean how precisely you can spot the
signal source in the brain like in in
what accuracy how fast so I mean
temporal resolution so how fast or in
what in which frequency we can measure
it and by safe I mean invasiveness of
this or if it's safe or it needs surgery
actually it's invasive or not invasive
so if we want to do it precise and safe
we have functional magnetic resonance
imaging it is completely safe we can
measure with millimeter accuracy the
signal source of the brain if we have if
we want to have it precise and fast we
have micro arrays of electrodes injected
directly into the brain but it needs
surgery so it's not very safe for you
and the most popular one is the EEG is
fast safe but it's very unprecedented
where is the signal source it's like
trying to understand a person in a
crowded restaurant but for the wall of
this restaurant something like this and
this triangle here was just for a
presentation because there are at least
two more dimensions in the
devices one is a price and in term in
terms of price the fMRI is quite a big
cost so it's not very usual to have one
in your house or in your scientific
institution so the EEG is the most
common or popular method of brain
reading and I will be focused on this
here the a multi fat book the low-cost
Davis devices like in in general I will
talk maybe some of the of the
professional EEG I will be doing
research on my PhD okay and if you want
to have some more details I can invite
you on the battlefield processing better
future site to read more on my blog post
so what do I mean by mind reading the
term mind reading isn't like perfectly
specified in literature or scientific
works it's usually in in quotation marks
like science fiction think what the mind
reading so I'm not talking about the
left picture trying like telepathy or
some kind of no in the mind of another
human but I'm talking about all methods
of computational neuroscience that can
make sense of the brain signals so
that's what I mean by mind reading not
like black mirror maybe black mirror
future but I will be not talking about
black mirror are we talking about
reality so last year Facebook it is a
picture from Facebook conference f8 last
year and they are trying to create
device that is able to type in your
computer or your mobile phone 100 words
per minute it is five times faster than
regular typing on the keyboard and
actually this mind typing isn't a new
thing it was shown by Facebook but the
first research in this area is from 1988
and it was based on some potential in
your head that is changing when you are
looking at the letter on the screen
the specific letter and this letter is
highlighted when it is highlighted there
is a special potential and you can
interpret it as a input to the computer
but what Facebook shown is a Stanford
University research and they didn't use
the dis potential that I said about
motor cortex just using one electrode in
the brain I will show the video they
were able to inject this electrode to
the paralyzed woman brain and use the
motor cortex to control the cursor on
the screen or the pointer on the screen
and it was quite smoothly it was big
success they use it also in robot arms
so this is the big the biggest success
of this of this team from Stanford
University to give the paralyzed tomb
and the ability to drink using the robot
arm this is from 2011 I think nature
video from YouTube you can see it as
well and the newest thing is the
prosthetic arm that can even feel the
feeling of touch in your hand so you can
control it using fully your brain
thoughts or your brain signals and even
feel there is someone touching it of
course it's after six months of
rehabilitation to to use this hand or to
control it in a proper way so the next
thing I would like to talk about is the
neural link the newest company of Elon
Musk and the mission of these companies
to create high bandwidth connection with
that between brain and computer and what
is the ultimate goal is to change the
communication speed of today because
even musk said if we cannot beat AI just
join it so just connect with the
computer
don't let be bitten by the AI just
joined the computer so the typing
talking or reading is too slow for evil
mask he wants all of the all of this
made in thinking time so just with the
very high bandwidth connection we can
connect with computers and other
people's in no time
actually there are some articles with
brain to brain communication like
playing playing Tetris between internet
and what what was this research about
here is the pong there are many of the
applications one person has a eg on the
head the second person has TMS it's like
brain stimulating machine by magnetic
field and the person that the receiver
one with these TMS was able to learn
what is the meaning of this magnetic
field in the in his brain and to rotate
or to play pong in the way that the the
person is seen that the center person is
seen so there was this very popular
interview from September where even
masks some had some smoking with event
and he said that I feel you have
something interesting to announce in a
few months that is at least at orders of
magnitude better than anything else
probably better than anyone thinks it is
possible it is about neural link and it
is before he smoked the weight so it can
be included more true than not so I'm
still waiting it been it's been like two
months from this event and other
applications we will see about neural
link but what are the other other
applications are a lie detection and
there are there is evidence that in
Guantanamo prisoners were exam I
examined by fMRI lie detectors and there
are articles that are saying that fMRI
experts experts in lie detection are 12
to 17 percent better than traditional
polygraph experts and there is also
identifying musical pieces using just
brain the
Brian device so we can tell which music
you are listening to in the same time by
just reading your mind and the most
interesting are mind blowing application
is reading visual information so reading
by your brain activity reading what you
are seen or even dreaming this is very
popular research top research subject in
papers right now so what I would like to
show you is the first fMRI from Purdue
University in from USA there is in fMRI
on the people that are watching some
clips video clips they are training
neural network to interpret the fMRI
Maps or the 3d maps and reconstruct
images from it this is the result it is
from 2017 the first research and the
second one okay this is the structure of
this network they used to reconstruct
the images from fMRI data I will not
talk about details here if you are
interested in you can check the article
actually the CNN Network was used as a
brain simulator or brain model of the of
the human to reconstruct and to classify
images of what humans see and this is
the research that many didn't believe
when it was released
it is reconstruction images from EEG EG
data is mostly very noisy and not very
informative it's not precise like I said
but he results of researchers from
Toronto was able to find the meaning to
reconstruct the faces of images I will
show you in the video too
and it was very famous application for a
few months it is from the beginning of
this year so just using EEG like a
professional video like you saw like for
the fifteen thousand dollars they
trained the SVM not deep learning it's
not deep learning is VM to make meaning
from brain signals and reconstruct the
faces if it is it is not faces from
training set or the same faces but just
the whole face space so you can see the
application have it watch the demo and
each face presentation the brain change
changes the activity and we can
interpret it by this SVM model to
reconstruct pixel by pixel actually the
the face we are seeing and at the end I
would like to show you a little demo
based on my article the latest article
about using this low-cost device
I will shown the other slide it is
something between this neural sky the
one electrode devices and the
professional devices it has 14 electrons
it is like very simple to do well of
course we need some saline to wet the
sand source because because it is
water-based not like gel or something
like this and it is quite cheap now we
have black Black Friday so we can buy it
for six hundred forty dollars if if
someone is interested of course you can
see it after presentation this device I
will not show the demo because the demos
from the Protestant are actually based
on EMG so the activity of the muscles
not the activity of the brain if you
would like to use it like real
mind-reading I will show you how ok so
what was this research about this my
research we have faces of happy I mean a
neutral or happy and angry people and we
try to
the difference in the brain activity for
neutral neutral faces and emotional
faces so there was the point of this
research we have we recorded and
designed this experiment hit open open
vibe is this open source presentation
software from India Institute and this
small rectangle here was used for
synchronizing that this device with
exact presentation moment on one keynote
we heard that it's impossible to really
find some exact moment in the video
where some emotion can be can be noticed
but here we have just the presentation
of a face face by face like a blank
screen and face and this smaller
rectangle here is for synchronizing for
the diode that I made so what can we do
to start in Python to process this
information in Python we have 14
channels 14 time sequences so we can use
M&E it is equivalent of MATLAB EEG lab
it isn't the most popular one in
scientific community but we can use it
in Python by just install in a many
people install M&E and it's fun funded
by some grants scientific grants
American and French grants and it is
compatible with numpy side by side learn
and I will show you some bits of code in
M&E so first I will load the data from
this Emotiv EPOC from this experiment it
is synchronized so it is called
processed because what we need to do is
to synchronize the markers from this
rectangle this signals from the diode
with the real markers because they are
changing or they are not synchronizing
well in this device so I will run this
to show you
how this signal looks like so this is
the signal from these 14 14 channels or
actually 12 here because 2 electrodes
are used for this diode
they are like connectors for this diode
to synchronize the events directly in
the signal this is completely messy and
noisy I was very skeptic about this at
the beginning of my research but it
shows up that after some processing here
I know that the bad channels are t7 and
f3 I will not talk about detail what
what are the meaning of these letters
and numbers but there are some standard
systems of position in these devices on
the head and they are called by letter
and number and the pre-processing we
have set in the average of these signals
the set reference average what what is
it is doing it is just taking the
average of all signals and where every
reference in the signal of all channels
to this one baseline and of course we
have filtering of the signals so we
don't want to have DC level we have we
want to have zero level so no just
floating like in the 10 minutes round
range of time we don't want this float
and we don't we don't want these very
fast oscillations so we are filtering
the data now it looks better this signal
and what we can do at the end we can
just select the epochs and by epoch I
mean one phase presentation so each
phase presentation is one epoch so we
put by epoch by epoch by epoch and it
was like 240 times in each experiment
why we need this because only 5% of the
activity we are measuring is connected
to the task so to get rid of the any
different signals we need to average
like few or several dozens of of this
kind of epochs we can find some
similarities between this
like this peek in in the beginning of
this epoch but only after every gene we
can notice we cannot okay this is the
average signal of all epochs and all
channels and we can see at the time of
170 milliseconds the peak in the down
peak and it is connected with face
processing of the brain it is well known
what a potential it is called even
relate event related potential of faces
negative 170 and then we have potential
connected with emotional processing it
is all like found in the psychological
research connected with emotional
processing and we have channels here the
channels here are from the back of the
head the occipital side and we can see
on the topographic map here that the
blue back of the head means low or
negative potential and the red forehead
means positive potential on the front of
the head and what what we can do is in
this diode synchronization if you use
just this device what I'm what I would
like to talk is that it's not very
precise in terms of time synchronization
so if you want to use it in like
mind-reading experiments you need to be
aware of these synchronization problems
you can analyze the probability signal
probability density of frequency I mean
just use Fourier transform
transformation and analyze the
frequencies in this signal and you can
also make a classifier using these
frequencies but to use time domain or
just event related potentials you need
this modification and at the end of this
research we were able to statistically
of course but because we can average
these epochs and measure only
statistically if it's possible to
distinguish between neutral phase and
emotional phase
so this is the results for one
participant so four neutral faces and
twenty positive signal in an 2250 was
different than for emotional ones and it
was statistically significant but still
it is very cheap device and the only
goal was if to check if there is any
difference and there was a difference it
was published and now we are going
further and trying to find more more
applications of this low-cost devices of
course I'm also working now on research
grade devices and trying to make some
processing because I'm computer
scientist and trying to do some machine
learning on it in terms of machine
learning we have more different
libraries in Python here you've got
slide if you want to use some of them
especially interesting this one and I
learn it is based on scikit-learn but
more prepared for eg processing or
signal brain signal processing and thank
you you can contact me on these
different channels of communications I
hope you enjoyed
[Applause]